the imf this week said quote the war in
ukraine means hunger in africa the world
food program is also warning of a
catastrophe saying half of the grain it
uses to feed the needy originates in
ukraine
but not only that it has also been
forced to slash aid to some african
countries because of the crisis
we're so short of funds already and now
with ukraine
we've uh
we've got 50 rations for people for
example in yemen i've just cut fifty
percent
rations for eight million people
niger 50 rashes chad 50 rations and 50
don't have anything those who are in
extreme need so it's already having a
global impact we've already seen
countries right before ukraine crisis
begin to destabilize like mali chad
burkina faso and in my opinion it's a
sign of things to come
we'll discuss this further with a
representative of the united nations
development program in a moment but
let's first go to somalia where an
almost forgotten humanitarian
catastrophe is now severely aggravated
by food aid being diverted elsewhere
somalia is experiencing its worst
drought in four decades millions are
starving and being forced to leave their
homes
bearing the brunt our children a warning
some viewers might find the following
pictures disturbing
we are only five kilometers away from
al-shabab control territory the islamist
terrorist group has a tight grip on
somalia
daily attacks have become normal
but terror is not the reason why roughly
30 000 people live in this camp
the drought has made their villages
uninhabitable
johara ali lost all her cows due to the
drought she has no food for her
four-year-old daughter
my daughter is getting worse every day
she can't keep anything down and is
vomiting
i tried to give her tea and powdered
milk
but she gets diarrhea straight away
there is no medicine in the camp
visiting doctors decide little uber has
to go to a hospital immediately
ngos warn of a humanitarian catastrophe
almost everyone here was a cattle farmer
until the drought killed their animals
three rainy seasons in a row have failed
somalia at the moment is facing
climate disaster manifesting itself
in displacement of massive populations
filling their homes in search of
life-saving assistance
in the hospital in the city of kismayo
malnourished children receive treatment
more than 10 have been admitted today
and the number is growing
the next morning we want to check on
little uber again
but the news is bad
we find out that the four-year-old girl
did not survive the night
after morning prayers she died
she'd lost a lot of fluids and hadn't
eaten at all
i will remember her as a happy girl
she always laughed with her siblings
increasing numbers of children are
falling ill because they do not have
enough to eat
but so far
way too little help has arrived
one reason is under funding
we are helpless to them we can't do
anything for them those people who are
being affected and their malnutrition
they lost their livestock we are not
doing anything for them
wfp says the problem is being
exacerbated by the war in ukraine food
supplies coming from there have dwindled
and some aid intended for somalia has
been redirected to ukraine there's a
number of donors at the beginning they
already told us that some commodities
are coming heading towards us those
committees were already diverted in this
in the sea
heading to ukraine
johara is now worried about her second
child abdi fatah he is also acutely
malnourished
on a good day the family gets one meal
but too often they go to bed hungry
let's talk more about this with ayodele
udusola resident representative and
director africa finance sector hub with
the united nations development program
he wrote a book on african agriculture's
potential performance lessons and
challenges hello sir thanks for your
time now food supplies are urgently
needed in somalia but this aid is being
diverted to ukraine due to the ongoing
war so who decides who lives and who
dies in such situations
thank you very much
what is important is the available
resources dedicated to countries
the resources available to
somalia
may be in short supply on the basis of
the need and my
call is that on the basis of what the
other u.n agencies are doing not only
the world food program alone is to
repurpose their
budget for this year to support
humanitarian aid all the unagencies that
are present that are working in somalia
are now repurposing and reprogramming
their budgets to support these
humanitarian aid but i just my call is
to avoid i mean to call on international
communities to support the country on
its current humanitarian need which is
very dear we have over 3 million people
needing humanitarian assistance with
over 300 000 children on the fire so we
want to really call an international
community to support and also we want to
see what we can do to mobilize from
other private international
organizations to support the situation
in somalia not only in terms of
humanitarian but also in terms of
technical support so that we can build
resilience they can we can build the
capacity of somalians to be able to
really produce food that they will need
and become okay exporter to the rest of
them
okay i mean you mentioned the numbers
yourself they are staggering to say the
least so what really goes into such
decisions
well what goes into the decisions uh is
about what is the budget regular budget
available to each agencies but we want
to go beyond that because what we want
to do is now to bring the international
private sector on board so that you can
mobilize resources from all other actors
that are even supporting humanitarian
assistance including the catholic relief
the bilateral what they call bilateral
donors to come and support and we need
to really show the reality on the ground
in somalia for us to be able to mobilize
more resources that will go into this so
it is my plea to international community
for us to really find a way of making
sure this is really achieved